foreign
hello everybody I am delighted to be
here and grateful to all of you for
joining us for this discussion
in 2015 I gave a tedx talk in a little
Elementary School auditorium and much to
my surprise the talk became one of the
10 most viewed talks in the history of
Ted
and in that talk I conveyed one simple
scientific finding
the finding that when we study hundreds
of people over their entire adult lives
the people who turn out to be the
happiest and the healthiest are those
who have good warm connections to others
so today I want to take you deeper into
this whole subject
by exploring how relationships matter in
our lives how they affect our health
what kinds of relationships give us this
big benefit in happiness and which tools
you can start using today to make your
relationship stronger
foreign
this Harvard study of adult development
it's as far as we know the longest study
of the same people that's ever been done
following people since 1938.
from adolescence all the way through old
age and now following all their children
thousands of lives
and
we began to find about 30 years ago this
startling connection between warm
relationships and how good our lives
feel to us our well-being and also the
fact that warm relationships seemed to
keep people both physically stronger and
kept their brains sharper as they grew
older
and we didn't believe the data at first
we thought how could this be that that
relationships actually get into our
bodies and shape our health
but then other studies began to find the
same thing
we found that people had less depression
they were less likely to get diabetes
and heart disease that they were covered
faster from illness when they had better
connections with other people
so then the question is how could this
work how do relationships shape our
happiness and our physical health
well one of the best theories for which
there's now some pretty good evidence is
based on the idea of stress that as we
know stress is an inevitable part of all
of our Lives stress happens to us every
day
and what we find is that good
relationships turn out to be stress
Regulators so let me give you an example
let's say that I have something
upsetting happen to me during the day
and I find myself like ruminating about
it and really thinking about it and
unhappy
I can feel my body go into what we call
fight or flight response where literally
my heart rate goes up and I might start
sweating a little bit and I'm just not
feeling as well
now what we're meant to do is to come
back to equilibrium when a stressor goes
away that's the way the body is supposed
to work
but what happens
if I go home at the end of my upsetting
day
and I have somebody to talk to
either I can call someone on the phone
or it's somebody I live with I can
literally feel my body calm down I can
feel that fight or flight response
subside
but what if I don't have anybody to go
home to what if there's nobody I can
call
what we find is that people who are
isolated are lonely don't have those
stress Regulators that we get from good
relationships and that we stay in
chronic fight or flight mode that our
bodies have this chronic stress
chronic levels of inflammation
and circulating stress hormones that
wear away our happiness and break down
different body systems
well what kinds of relationships seem
essential to well-being
and this is interesting we asked people
of who were our original participants in
our study we asked them who could you
call in the middle of the night if you
were sick or scared
and many of our people could list
several other people they could call if
they were in trouble some people
couldn't list anyone there wasn't a
person on the planet who they could turn
to if they were sick or scared and what
we find is that having at least one
person in your life who you feel really
has your back who you could go to if you
were in trouble That's essential for
maintaining our happiness and our health
when we asked
these same people when they got to be in
their 80s to look back on their lives
and to tell us what they were proudest
of almost everybody
said something about their relationships
they didn't say I made a lot of money or
I won some big Awards they said
I was a good Mentor I was a good friend
I raised healthy kids I was a good
partner
and so what we find is that what seems
to mean the most to people when they get
to the end of their lives is the
strength and the warmth of their
connections to others
so then the question comes up well which
types of relationships support our
well-being some people have asked do I
need to be in an intimate relationship
to get this benefit absolutely not all
types of relationships support our
well-being so friendships relatives work
colleagues casual contacts the person
who gets you your coffee every morning
at Starbucks or Dunkin Donuts the person
who checks you out in the grocery store
who you see maybe every week
even talking to strangers has that
benefit so
they did an experiment where they
assigned some people who were about to
go on the subway the task of talking to
a stranger while other people were
assigned the task of just doing their
usual thing of being on their phones or
listening to music or reading it turned
out that the people who were assigned to
talk to strangers didn't think they were
going to like it but they turned out to
be much happier at the end of the task
than the people who just rode the subway
keeping to themselves so even talking to
strangers gives us that little hit of
well-being from relationships
so the question comes up how can we
strengthen our connections with other
people
and this is where we've come to think
about it as a kind of Social Fitness if
we think about physical fitness you know
we we think okay I'll go to the gym I'll
work out I'll take a long walk I'll do
something to keep myself strong and fit
but then we come home and we don't say
I'm done I don't ever have to do that
again we have the sense that physical
fitness is a practice that we need to
maintain over time it turns out that
Social Fitness is the same that in fact
our friendships our relationships don't
just take care of themselves that even
good relationships need tending to they
need attention they need returning to
them over and over again so what are
some ways that we can strengthen our
relationships well one way is to be
proactive to take the initiative so to
reach out to a friend and ask her to
take a walk
instead of spending two more hours on
your laptop this weekend on Saturday
afternoon
establish some routines with the people
who are most important to you a regular
phone call or a coffee every Saturday
with someone you really want to be sure
you see regularly or meeting somebody at
the gym or having lunch with a co-worker
the other thing we can do is liven up
those long-standing relationships
particularly like the people we live
with you know people we can come to take
for granted by proposing to do something
new
going out on a date
um
uh just taking a walk if that's not your
usual routine
the other thing that we know Works to
help people particularly who aren't as
connected to others as they want to be
is to connect around shared interests so
volunteer in the community to do
something that you care about it might
be a gardening club it might be a
bowling league it might be a political
cause but to do something that you care
about because then you're with other
people who care about the same thing and
that's a natural place to start
conversations that can lead to ongoing
relationships
and finally
get more comfortable striking up casual
conversations that's something we can
learn to be more comfortable with almost
like exercising a muscle
so now
I would like to ask you
to do one of these things to make one of
these choices that we can make every day
I'd like you to make that choice right
now here's my challenge to you
think about someone you miss that you
just haven't seen in a while or you
haven't had contact with and you'd like
to make contact
you don't even have to have a particular
reason
now I want you to take out your phone or
whatever device you use right now and
send that person just a little note
it could say I'm just thinking of you
and wanted to connect
or you could say something more personal
to you and to your relationship
and then watch what comes back to you
and while we're here we might even have
time to share with each other some of
the responses that people get when they
do this
so
think of someone
and make contact right now the point of
this simple exercise is to remind us
that even small actions can have Ripple
effects that build our well-being and
that these are things you can do every
day
in the moment
thank you
one way I'd love to to kick things off
Bob you mentioned at the top of the
conversation the top of your talk rather
um that you run this Harvard study of
adult development and gave us sort of a
a snippet of what that is but could you
tell us a little bit more about the
study what what does a track why did why
did it start um who's in the study today
absolutely the study started in 1938 and
it started with two groups a group of
Harvard College undergrads
and it started with a group of inner
city boys who were in elementary school
or middle school from really
disadvantaged troubled families and each
study was trying to look at how people
can take healthy developmental paths and
so the idea was not to study what goes
wrong in our lives but what goes right
in our lives and some of the factors
that contribute to helping things go
well in human development needless to
say we we started out with boys all
males but we've added women uh we have
more than half women now and we've added
the second generation so we started out
with 724 people now we have over 2 000
people in our study and we're still
collecting data today
wow fine I know um in in the book you
you talk about
um how the the the
um advice you offer the wisdom you offer
is not just drawn from your own study
um because of some of what you suggested
that you know you're just now starting
to bring women and um different
generations and I guess could you talk
about some of the other gaps and why
it's been important to also think about
some of the uh um other studies out
there on on life and happiness
yes that's a really good point because
particularly in the this kind of
research no single study is proof of
anything that what we want is for
different studies of different
populations so different ethnic groups
different cultural groups different
geographies right we want different
studies to point in the same direction
and that's why I'm here and I can tell
you with confidence many studies point
to all these same benefits of
relationships
and I know you touched on um the health
element in your talk and share that
there is data that reveals that we have
that there's a strong connection between
happiness and health
and what have you specifically found
related to happiness and health outcomes
what we find is that happiness
turns out to make us age more slowly and
keep us able uh longer so the the
diseases of Aging that happen to all of
us happen later uh sometimes they don't
happen at all in people who are happier
have a greater sense of well-being and
it's because of what I spoke about a few
minutes ago this this kind of decrease
in chronic inflammation and chronic
stress and so what we find is that and
we can't guarantee that any one person
is going to stay happier or live longer
if they have better relationships but we
find that there are these ingredients
just like taking care of your health you
know not smoking not abusing alcohol or
drugs exercising regularly getting
regular Health Care having Access to
Health Care all of those things really
matter for our health
and you you start the book with a
question you say if you had to make one
life choice right now to set yourself on
the path to future health and happiness
what would it be and from hearing your
talk today we know that the right answer
to that question is to build more warm
connections but I want to ask you about
the use of the word choice there
um and understanding more about whether
or not having warm connections is a
choice that we make
um or to put it another way are there
qualities
um that each of us have that maybe make
us more social people
um that and that these are just baked
into our personalities can we decide to
be a person who makes connections
that's a really important point because
we differ we are we are all different in
how much connection we want and benefit
from so some of us are introverts and
that's just fine that's perfectly normal
and introverts don't want a lot of
connections in fact being with a lot of
people is exhausting for introverts and
so some people just need one or two good
relationships everybody needs a little
bit of connection
but some people actually don't need a
lot and so what we want to do is try to
figure out for ourselves what's right
for me and and that involves really just
tuning in and saying
okay I'm energized by being with a lot
of people so I'm gonna do that or no I'm
exhausted by being with a lot of people
for me you know a quiet conversation
with one person is the most energizing
thing I can do in the interpersonal
realm and so it's really a matter of
discerning what's right for each person
and what factors have you found
contribute to that maybe things from
early in life or childhood that might
actually shape our ability to to make
these connections later in life
yes so many of our social skills we
learn when we're growing up we learn it
in our families we learn it at school
and on the playground they they can be
learned and they can be improved as we
get into adulthood they're not set in
stone once we're done with childhood
um so it's really important to
see the ways that you know just like
some of the suggestions I made ways that
you can practice getting better at this
because it really pays off
but some people are not so good at this
and they can have perfectly wonderful
happy healthy lives without being Social
Butterflies and extroverts and I just
want to name that so that people don't
go away thinking gosh if I'm not an
extrovert I'm out of luck not true at
all many of our happiest people had
quieter lives
and you know I guess to to the the tips
that you offered in the talk um you know
you talked about how we can build one
connection steps that we can take
um and this idea of Social Fitness
um and so I'm curious how how can we
actually assess our social Fitness and
as you said to sort of understand what
is right for us in terms of how many
friends to have and and is it possible
to to sustain warm relationships if you
aren't really intentional in thinking
about your Social Fitness
that question of how do we assess our
social Fitness
um it's really checking in and saying am
I as connected as I would like to be to
other people and if I'm not what am I
missing so not all relationships provide
us with the same stuff
some relationships are relationships we
have because they're fun
you know so and and so they're the
people I like to go out and party with
some relationships are the relationships
that help me when I'm scared or hurting
or worried about something and I need
someone to talk things over with I need
a sounding board a good advisor some
relationships are the people who you
know loan me tools when I need to fix
something and I don't have the right
tool or give me a ride to the doctor so
part of it is checking in about what am
I missing and then seeing what might be
possible in terms of
developing more of the relationships
that give us the things we want more of
um and along those same lines Ted number
Tiana wants to know how how do we Define
if a relationship is actually meaningful
or not I mean it sounds like
understanding what these voices are
saying but are there other things we
should pay attention to to know if it's
valuable if this is a one connection
yeah
one way to think about it is not not
whether the relationship is smooth all
the time but whether
we feel that we can be authentic we can
be ourselves in a relationship and
obviously we won't be the same selves in
a work relationship that we might be
with our you know beloved sister
um you know but
still can I be myself in the most
essential ways can I express myself and
can the other person Express themselves
because I think that's where what we
really want is to feel known and to feel
seen and not to feel like we are having
to maintain a a facade that hides who we
are and so the best relationships are
those where we feel we can be ourselves
and you talked about how really it's
it's romantic relationships friendships
acquaintances I mean all of these
relationships matter but do you find
that one of these is maybe more
significant than the other or how do you
look at them
I look at it in terms of the secure
attachment we think about it that's
attachment is a word for being warmly
securely connected it's the who can you
call in the middle of the night if
you're sick or scared so I think of it
in those terms not not necessarily the
person's role defined role in our life
like romantic partner or
um or boss but it's the does this person
have my back and so that's I think the
the defining element that we want to
find somewhere in our world
um so we have so many member questions
coming in Bob and I'm gonna um kind of
go through a little a few more of them
um well so Ted member Nancy wants to
know if you think it's possible for an
endemically unhappy person at some point
in life to obtain happiness yes and
thank you for asking that question so we
have a couple of life stories in our
book the book contains real stories of
real people every the names are
disguised to protect confidentiality but
some of those stories are of people who
have big turnarounds late in life people
who were isolated and less happy and in
their 60s found a whole Community one
man found a community at a gym that he
never dreamed he would find and so the
message that we get from studying these
thousands of lives is
it is never too late and so don't assume
that it's too late for you even if you
feel like you've had not had good luck
with this in the past well Bob we're
we're getting some questions um about
you and I want to turn to you for a
second
um and I'm curious how running this
study has changed the way you approach
life and
um your own pursuit of happiness
ah gosh well one of the things that's
helped me with is the idea that
everybody
has struggles in their life that has
been so meaningful to me because I can
also look at the world and say gee other
people seem to have lives that have it
all figured out and perfect lives it is
so helpful to know
that there isn't a person on the planet
who doesn't have struggles and it makes
me feel less alone uh when I can
recognize that and that's one of the
reasons why I want to keep getting these
messages out after having studied
thousands of lives
and I think the other thing that it's
changed is my own
priorities so I realize okay I can sit
here this afternoon and edit another
paper or do more work or I can see my
friend who I haven't seen in a month and
so I've become more active in taking
care of my relationships and it makes a
big difference so I would say that those
are the two big things for me that that
directing this study has changed about
my life well we have a question from Ted
member Nissa they ask as a mother of two
very young children what advice do you
have for parents to build strong healthy
relationships now that
um now through adulthood
four parents
it's it's really helping
helping your children to pay attention
to
how they feel and to learn to use their
feelings with more choice so learning to
love what they love and hang on to what
they love even if it's not so popular
you know I had a a mother talk to me
about how her child really loved doing
improv comedy and he's only 12 and his
friends don't like that and so we talked
about how do you help your child feel
supported in loving what he loves and
and taking an improv class right
um so helping your kids learn that it's
okay to love something that's not the
same as all the other kids in their
group uh and keep loving what they love
and helping kids learn that it's okay to
be unhappy and that that will pass that
feelings come and go that it's okay to
disagree
um families can model parents can model
for kids we can have disagreements we
can work it out and and hold on to the
these good relationships even through
disagreements those are some of the
biggest lessons we can
help our children with about how to use
their feelings rather than kind of Be
buffeted by their feelings and ruled by
their feelings I'm curious just where
you see the study going from here we are
collecting more data even as we speak we
are we are collecting more information
from the children almost all the
original participants have passed away
but their children are all baby boomers
on average and so we're collecting
information including
about what life was like during the
pandemic also collecting information
about how they use social media which is
something we've all been talking about a
bit here
um and I think in terms of the future
we see ourselves as wanting to make our
data available to more and more
researchers
so we want to collaborate and we do
collaborate with other research groups
we say come in and use our data and ask
new questions that we don't even think
to ask because we have this Treasure
Trove of information about thousands of
lives and then we're going to make it
publicly available on public websites
because you know much of our work has
been funded by the federal government by
NIH with taxpayer money and so we feel a
responsibility to make this information
available to other researchers who want
to ask their own questions about our
data
um well Bob you've shared so many great
things with us
um you know I feel like if if people
were listening and trying to absorb all
of it um and at the very end of this
conversation one just one nugget of
information that if you missed
everything what is the one thing um that
you want everyone to walk away from uh
at in this conversation
that if you want to make one choice
today that will make you healthier and
happier it is to pay attention to
improving your connections with other
people that that is such a good
investment and it will pay off for years
to come
[Music]
foreign
[Music]